what sorts of things do you think that
you know you should try to do to get
this caliber of guy that you want to
start this family
with
um I guess
um from what you're saying it sounds
like I need to be more of a
woman what kind of woman can you
describe
her
I don't know because I feel like I do
both well I mean like I can cook I'm a
great cook I can clean I
can like do all these things I don't
feel like it's necessarily a bad thing
if I want to like lift heavy weights and
know how to work on a
car are you like a a powerlifter like
what kind of training do you do at the
gym
I want to
be I'm I'm still I've been in the gym
for like four years now
um and I
am I want to like do like uh bikini
modeling but I'm not toned enough for
that or muscular enough for that so I've
got a long way to go um you're you're 5
foot five right yes so a bikini model at
5 foot5 on a stage is going to be
somewhere around 120 125 pound probably
so yes if you don't mind me asking how
much do you
we uh I am
185 yeah so women are Beauty objects to
men right and like a fitness mod like I
like fit women with curves right so I
know exactly what the height and weight
matches for that and I and I've dated a
lot of women like that like my gal looks
like that today but but a but a fit
women with with curves is very
attractive to a good chunk of the male
population you would be spoiled for
choice at 55 and 125 pounds so I think
that one of the main areas in in your
life that I would focus on that I
haven't even heard you say yet I can
work on cars I can cook I can clean I
got a great job I make lots of money
it's like the biggest thing that you got
to do is get down to a healthy
weight
yes because I mean part of the reasons
why you're dealing with some of these
losers is because of that because men do
view women as Beauty objects and women
do view men as success
objects it's far more powerful when it
comes to women and their attract I mean
the one thing that I tell guys and girls
and it's more impactful for women
because of guys being more attracted to
to the surface and the superficiality
and and looks but the fastest way to
increase your chances or to get better
options when it comes to dating is your
physical appearance guys getting in the
gym guys that are you know learn how to
lift heavy weight build a masculine
muscular physique you know women build
nice curves uh have them in the right
places it's it's not going to solve the
problem entirely for men it'll get you a
lot closer to where you want to be as a
woman because that's what men are most
you know aptly driven too and are are
targeting um everybody could could heed
that advice and and starts with
physicality but women even more so like
it's I mean you see the kind of [__]
that guys put up with for for hot women
like women don't usually put up with
[__] from a hot guy if he doesn't
have everything else going for him and
doesn't have all his ducks in a row the
guys will put up with a ton of [__] and
they will fall over themselves for
beautiful women I mean rich and I get
emails messages all the time where guys
will you know the justification is ah
she's this she brow beats me and she's
that and she's this and she you know
texts other guys and but she's the
hottest girl I've ever been which but
she's super hot rich like that's the
enough for a lot of yeah if you watch
the Monday night shows you'll get you
know you get these guys call again and
it's
like I have I have very different
conversations with men than you know
than what I do with women like with guys
it's like dude you have to get your [__]
together Chase aon's put a dent in the
universe be competent be muscular like
you know lose the weight too like you
can't be fat when you're a guy right
like women like the Vaper right you know
you've you know you've described a fit
muscular guy but the contrast of that
you know for women is you've you've got
to become a like your your priority in
developing yourself and calibrating
yourself to capture that dude has has
got to be to focus on yourself as a
beauty object and you know like the
standards of nice hair and hair color
and eyelashes and nails and all that
sort of stuff that's just the icing on
the cake but what but what guys are
looking at generally is is she fit now
there's a contingent of guys out there
that do like bigger you know thicker
women but I don't know like I roll in
circles with entrepreneurs and guys that
make six seven eight figures a lot of
them you know have very very cool
businesses and I've never seen like any
of these guys show up at an event with
an overweight woman right like they love
the fit women it's always a given so
that's the main area you know to focus
on rather than boss girl I want to own a
dealership you know I can change a spark
plugs in an El El Camino it's like you
know I was watching the chat when you
were sort of you know describing all
that and guys are like don't care don't
care don't care don't care don't care
don't care it's like you know the
culinary skills are an awesome start you
know being able to feed a man is a
wonderful thing especially if you've got
great skills there um you know there's
an old sayyan if you can keep his
stomach full and his balls empty he's
never going to leave you sort of thing
right and that and that's got nothing to
do with changing spark plugs in a car
being a boss girl and wanted to run a
dealership and by the way the notion of
like having four kids I think is
wonderful I think you know kids are a
great thing it's like a lost art in
today's world and it's you know it's
gotten to the point where women will
chase a career climb the corporate
ladder stop get married have kids pop
them out and then go back to work and
drop them off at daycare and if you've
paid any attention to what's going on in
the world out there today with the
education system and the wokeness and
the infusion of acceptance and
everything that's [__] today you're
basically handing off your
Offspring the things that you've sired
to pass on your DNA and your name to
leave a legacy in the hands of people
that are probably going to shove
pronouns and rainbows and all kinds of
crap down their throat and tell them you
know you're beautiful at any whatever
sort of thing see what I'm saying like I
think it's a much more beautiful thing
to stay home and raise the kids and you
imprint on them and you know you're able
to give them that uh version of yourself
so that that moves on into
perpetuity because right now we've got
this Empire of nothing we've got this
world where it's
like it's just beige it just sort of
Blends in like there's no color to it
anymore how does that s with
you I love all of that it was very
insightful I'm
glad we're getting somewhere on the show
moth we trying we're trying anyway but
surely I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out